for these children who once lived in the
largest prison in Lusaka education is a
luxury and face my supe has made it
possible for them a few years ago she
founded an organization called mother of
Millions
it looks after women prisoners and their
babies in Zambia's capital and helps
them adjust to the world outside after
their release the only thing that mother
of millions wants to do is to ensure
that the women get training and they're
able to stand by themselves independent
in the community because sometimes it's
hard to reintegrate into community or
society you know because of the stigma
that goes with it
my mother of Millions is supported by
donations the organization is often
short on cash so classes for the
children are usually held in faiths home
faith then drives the mothers to a
training center the ride takes them past
the city's Central Prison which houses
over 1,000 inmates men women even
children when I was pregnant with my son
I decided to pass through the prism on
my left and I was shocked to find
children in prison
the conditions of these children were
pathetic
children was subject to the same
portions of their as their mother they
were sleeping in cells like their mother
and they were treated as prisoners and
today they're caught circumstantial
children we decided to make a difference
by creating a classroom and impacting
the lives of these children classes
continue after the women are released
from prison mothers learn how to run
small businesses so they can generate a
source of income sure that they get an
education in literacy learning and
business skills and by so doing they are
able to stand independently themselves
faith often has to teach the children
the most basic skills four-year-old
Joseph is on his first excursion after
life in prison there's much to discover
faith is nearby keeping a watchful eye
the first time Joseph has been in such
an open place such a place where he can
feel like a child again
and that's his right I think he's
enjoying what is happening to him I'm
happy for him Joseph now enjoys his
freedom but for the many other children
still living in Zambia's prisons faith
my supa plans to build the first school
behind prison walls in Zambia